لقد أمضينا يومًا كبيرًا اليوم في كازاخستان Whoa
Moe ألقِ نظرة على هذا حسنًا ، هنا
المزرعة الرسمية من الطابق السفلي
تم تطهيرها من قبل CDC.
مركز السيطرة على الأمراض ،
ليس لديها حمى ، فأنت تعرف
الأعراض بعد مجموعة الأيام من
الحجر الصحي ، ما زلنا خائفين قليلاً ،
لذا
سأعطيك واحدة من هذه فقط أعطيك واحدة من هذه فقط أعطيك واحدة
من هذه فقط  أنت واحد من هؤلاء
Bella قد أخذ الفيديو بالطبع ،
هذا هو الحلم لمجرد العودة إلى
هنا للقيام بأشياء عادية ولكن ما
قد لاحظته هناك سانجاي
مرحبًا بك بهدوء شديد عندما صعدت
السلالم لسببين مثل
البصل الذي تم أسره لا يريدونني حقًا
أن أخرج من الطابق السفلي ، لكن ثانيًا ،
لقد أخاف هذا العائلة التي تعرف
ما أعنيه أننا خائفون من هذه
العائلات التي تحدثت إليها في جميع
أنحاء البلاد ، لقد هزتنا حقًا عندما
حصلت على قضية وإن كانت كثيرة  أكثر
اعتدالًا من أنا وأعتقد أنها
أقوى مما أنا عليه ،
لكن انخفاض عدد
الفتيات الآفات أثر علينا ، فقد أخاف الأطفال وهناك
القليل من الصدمة وعملية التعافي
التي يتعين علينا أن نمر
بها كما أنت  رؤية جميع العائلات التي
لم أسمع بها من قبل عن التعافي ، لم أكن أعلم
أن هذا كان كما تعلم كنت تعاني
من نوع من الصدمات مثل صدمات الأطفال والآن
لدي عملية تعافي مدتها ثلاثة أسابيع ، قمت
بالجزء الأول اليوم ، وبالكاد أستطيع التنفس
أثناء المشي 25  دقائق شعرت
وكأنني منهكة